first thing I've ever jacked off to was
the album Mercedes she's on a on the low
rider she's bent over in jean shorts I
was probably I don't know nine ten
jacked off to that what is it Mercedes
album the album video would date a black
girl and have a kid and they would have
the highest ass of all time dude yeah
top left it'd be in the shoulders some
good times with that my mom would take a
[ __ ] like this
this hot that's how she drives her ass
look
laughs
just that high ass yeah Theo got a high
ass booty I remember that comic black
ass son
wait I remember this yeah wow it's
called rear end this is unbelievable No
Limit Records son now her face like fat
and I remember in the picture back there
you jerked off to that oh hard daddy
daddy nine years old about I don't know
maybe 12 I don't know
you said don't lie about that I don't
remember it was the first one
when did this come out Nick
her face is fat huh all right well you
know it's like hey is that man hey wait
hold on this is your [ __ ] I know yeah
yeah you jacked off to that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know it's the king and the sting and
the wing
foreign
[Music]